[Music]
[Applause]
let's get to the poll question then
we'll bring in our friend rich eisen
from the nfl network todd
okay poll question kyla murray
i told you i have all these screens up
so i had i need this i just need that
extra second of your time kyle murray
wants his new deal now 71
once out of arizona 29
i can hear michael michael irvin in the
hall
[Laughter]
well you work with him every every year
i i can sense him i know when he's near
dan um but he is near
can you hear him in the hallway yeah uh
full intro rich eisen nfl network host
you can see him a special eight and a
half hour edition of nfl game day
morning
sunday at nine eastern on nfl network
not enough to talk about we showed a
promo last night
um
and um
there were 21 of us on the screen
they actually worked they actually
photoshopped 21 human beings
on a screen and you know how i even
texted you about this when when peacock
made a promo for nbc sports on peacock
yeah and i i always notice
who's in the center who's on the side
who has shoulder on another because you
know when they photoshop somebody in
they photoshop in somebody behind you or
in front of you and
um i let it be known um you know i i
require shoulder
um when it comes to photoshopping in a
promo and i noticed on the peacock one
you had shoulder
on me and
but that's
but that's in my contract i didn't know
that yes
these are things i need to work on um
until i you know i need to make it yeah
who's got shoulder take a look at all
these promos like last night when uh for
the for the super bowl opening night
show
um i you know interviewed burrow and
stafford together and they put a promo
for that together and they gave me
shoulder on both super bowl quarterbacks
and it might be the only time i have
shoulder on both super bowl quarterbacks
congratulations it's a long time coming
it has been long building long time ago
the momentum has been building i mean
i'm looking for a sports emmy you're
looking for shoulder well you have one
of those no we don't oh collectively
yeah we
we're we're over the last four
uh
well i mean i mean we're the buffalo
bills you're the puff we're the buffalo
bills we are four consecutive losses so
basically
are you saying that pti has shoulder on
yes they do
yes because i'm assuming that is the
show mlb tonight beat us one time i
thought nhl tonight was going to edge us
out one one time but yeah if you lose to
pardon the interruption i'm okay with
that okay yeah all right i'm all right
yeah yeah that you you i mean it's only
22-minute show i mean you know this is
three hours they don't take that into
consideration no they don't no they
don't i love how people always go
man i'd love to do that your show you
know you just get to talk all the day
all day and i go okay why don't you try
it yeah give it a whirl like go three
hours let me know how you do you and you
know what happens usually they go 15
minutes that first 15 minutes they're on
fire they got stories they got
everything on they go right what am i
going to talk about from now on first
year i was on the air um you know on
audience back in our the old days
um i the first year
that my show was on there was like 2014
i guess so i was still doing
thursday night football on the road for
nfl network so the fridays after
thursday night i would have fill in
hosts and i decided you know why not
have like the old carson days have a
celebrity fill-in host
so i would offer the three hours to
celebrities
and
they just didn't quite grasp the
three-hour nature of it so one year one
friday i had bobby carnevale the actor
do it
and i saw him after the show i flew back
in and i saw him that night and he's
like i had to take a nap i am wiped out
and i'm like dude you do like broadway
you do two shows in a day yeah you do a
wednesday matinee and a wednesday
wednesday night or saturday matinee like
you do eight hours of live acting he
goes yeah but i know what i'm going to
say that's true
and he goes not knowing what i to say it
wipes you out somebody has scripted all
of that that's the thing people go you
know as you're scripted i go no you
can't of course not yeah it's like
yesterday i was on rich's show and we
found out about kyle murray scrubbing
his you know social media accounts of
the uh the arizona cardinals you go this
is going to be a big deal yeah as soon
as you see that in the 21st century this
is something you can read into what's
this about
i hear you guys your poll question the
first hour i can't believe it would be
money because somebody of his
you know um stature should understand
the money's coming
um and
you know um
on top of it i understand that you know
you you you think the money's coming but
you never know that said
winning a super bowl in your first
contract is what
you're supposed to do
and that's how
deandre hopkins winds up out here and
how they can afford to work in aj green
and tj and jj watt you know and and so
on and so forth that build your team out
if you're going to start demanding to be
paid now
that would be a problem that said he
does see josh allen getting his when he
got it and he might be pitching a fit
but i i
i don't see how
this works what they're just gonna see
wow you
you only have two instagram photos now
you had 300 yeah
look out i guess we should start forking
over something that starts with a four i
mean like what's that all about yeah i
don't know what the end game is but it
just feel it felt like i want to get
paid maybe i
upped the time frame and i get paid a
year earlier or you can utilize your two
sports star status
when the other sport is not
locking out yeah you know like this is
the wrong time yeah the timing the
leverage timing i'm gonna go play
baseball where in japan like is that
where is that your plan yeah i don't
know how that works yeah and i don't
know if you know what his leverage has
to get out of there i don't know if he
has a problem now with cliff kingsbury
and the way he calls
plays and what
it feels like kyler murray because of
his contract they were able to
bring in some veterans as you mentioned
that made you formidable
you know it's not like you're there with
josh rosen with you know the talent he
had or didn't have you know you have a
good team you're in a very competitive
division yeah they were the last
remaining undefeated team of this year
so
it's just that that that team with
kingsbury has had an
odd way of fading down the stretch yeah
and i don't know how
this
addresses that at all so i don't know
what it is
i don't know at all what it is but also
as you pointed out when you were on my
show yesterday
his strategy sometimes
oh you're you're grasping at straws as
to why somebody would say appear at a
super bowl when there's a question is he
going to play which sport make himself
available to somebody like yourself
and then expect that you're going to
walk out of that interview without being
pressed on that one subject you don't
want to talk about so how does that
happen and you know what people don't
realize is rich interviewed kyler murray
before we had him on live
now a good friend would have come down
the hall
to to tell him he's too fast he's proven
he's too fast his escape ability dan
that day was remarkable no
because i saw rich after and and he goes
yeah he wasn't very good with us either
and i go
and i'm thinking why didn't you tell me
that i could have just said hey it all
worked out i think oh
that worked out i don't know yeah paulie
and i disagree i think that's good
producing by rich he didn't uh spoil it
and he had just walked him down i
thought you'd get something out of it oh
i warmed him up i was a warmed up tyler
murray that you got on your property oh
my god mine didn't get aired till later
so and all i was asking you have to have
an answer for what sport are you going
to play or do you want to play
and i had somebody who told me about 20
minutes before hey i see where you got
kyle murray on text me uh you know he's
going to play football if he's you know
top 10 top five pick he's definitely
playing football so i brought it up to
kyler and he's like
he's just like yeah and then his dad was
like 50 feet away and i'm yelling across
the room to his dad i'm asking his dad
questions is he going to play yeah he's
right he's playing baseball football
hello
unbelievable um so rich eisen is here
hosting the super bowl
a home super bowl for the nfl network
yes sir and normally you're on the road
and you're calling home yeah i know now
this time around i'm actually having a
parent dan um normally it's just dad's
facetiming for 90 seconds and they don't
want to talk on facetime anyway so yeah
now i'm actually having to go home and
parent so
if you got any suggestions anybody
you know
normally i'm just sitting in a hotel
just keeping my head down but this has
just been and plus the nfl network
um we're now across the street from the
stadium so our network is inside the
security perimeter of the super bowl so
that adds an extra layer of uh
fascinating uh
status so it but it's great i honestly
in 2003 when we moved out here at the
network
and started it up and people were like
what are you doing in los angeles
there's no nfl in la at all poor sam
farmer of the la times was the only guy
at the state of the state for the
commissioner raising his hand and asking
questions about l.a and everyone's
looking like weirdo what are you talking
about like why are you keeping on
keeping the flame lit now
five and a half billion dollar stadium
nfl network's got a new spot across the
street from it two nfl
teams play there one of them is playing
in the actual super bowl here it's
unbelievable it sets up nicely for the
rams but the pressure on the rams yeah
to win this super bowl yeah is what um i
would say
you know i i know everybody's saying
it's house money for the bengals
um
you know if the rams
lose the super bowl it's not going to
cost anybody a job
um i don't i i
fully believe less need has things set
up where it's not like
some people have got to go
i think they'll be able to figure out to
keep vaughn and o'dell and everybody
kind of digs it here they really like
each other i don't sense any
you know when you see a team like
they've gotta win now they're all in
they're gonna break up um there might be
some fissures within the front office
there might be something like that i i
just think if there is any pressure it
would be when are you going to get back
uh although stafford thinks i i would
think that he's in a great spot
um
that said it would be a great
momentum um for the rams to win this
game and help build a fan base yeah
that's what i was wondering about the
fan base but i i was looking at this if
stafford wins and plays well yes he's
going to go the hall of fame i agree
if joe burrow wins now he's halfway to
the hall of fame right it feels like
he's in that russell wilson patrick
mahomes category of wow you got one
first two well i think that if if borrow
wins it's not so much a hall of fame
talk i think the the the talk is well
here's somebody where and this is the
way it's going to be for the rest of our
lives and our kids lives
i think maybe our grandchildren's lives
is
is this guy someone who can catch brady
i think this is the oh
yes this is the conversation you're
going to start to hear
well i don't know i don't i mean i don't
think that well you're you're going to
start to look for can anybody catch
brady whoever can catch brady is
somebody who's going to come out of
college
and do what he did which he would match
tom
for his first in two years
he would also have this sort of
cool aspect about him
that has the it factor that tom sort of
began to grow into i think that's the
conversation that you're going to hear
not just so much the hall of fame is
that can
borrow
be the guy to do this and i know you
mentioned mahomes
but you know pat is two years you know
two super bowls in and he's only one
year in so borrow would kind of match
him already yeah but mahomes is two
years older
and it feels like kansas city is still
going to be kansas city well cincinnati
could be the new kansas city cincinnati
might not even be the favorites in the
afc north next year then that's great it
could be the ravens i i don't know why
if the
if the bengals win the super bowl
they would not be the favorite i don't i
don't know i just throw that out there i
just well my job is to throw questions
out
that's i just i appreciate it don't
throw it back to me that's how you have
shoulder down yes that's how you have
shoulder that's how you gain
shoulder status you know and i think
they elevated your height in the promo
to make you look a little bit well i
told them that it was smaller like i
talk about these things i don't care you
know my montreal
he sent me the picture and i go uh i got
other things to worry about no well what
i said is i kind of feel like you're
telling me to suck it in the background
yes you did and you said never no i
wouldn't said you never would do that i
i would numb
so yeah i mean so
i i with burrow winning this is the
conversation i think you're going to
have
um that who can catch him and every kid
that comes out of college that wins the
if he's fortunate enough to win a super
bowl for the first time uh in just year
two you're gonna hear that and if
somebody comes out of college and wins
it as a rookie then then we're off and
running we're gonna constantly be
looking to see who can actually catch
this guy which is what the conversation
was last year if mahomes beats brady
then you know now brady wins he'll keep
him at arm's distance so on and so forth
but i wonder though if burrow wins now
all of a sudden he's on equal footing
with
you know mahomes yes
uh russell right and uh rogers i mean in
terms of being super yes yeah i mean
that
because we're waiting now that tom's
retired or at least we think he's
retired why why would you say never say
never
this whole just lie you lied to jim last
week about retiring why don't you lie
this week
now he's now he's being honest i totally
don't get anything
about the brady retirement
plan execution
anything i don't understand anything
about it where it wasn't it wasn't
discussed all year long kind of get that
don't want to uh don't want a a tour
don't want you know the jeter big poppy
sort of
uh retirement tour rivera you don't want
that or you really are thinking about it
then it comes out that you're out
but you won't say you're out
because you have a plan
we think
and then the plan is either scrapped or
it never existed
and then clearly the plan wants the
cat's out of the bag has got to be on
your own podcast right and then he
doesn't
and then
instagram retires the next day
and then six days later
cracks the door back open i don't
okay but imagine he's doing this podcast
at home
and jim gray's asking the question and
giselle is just eavesdropping at the
house and all of a sudden you know she's
hearing jim say so you know
think about coming back well you never
say never and you know all of a sudden
gizelle's at the door
and she finishes she's she finishes it
like mike tomlin but never
you know like never say never i'll just
say the butt never you know uh in in
this house setup are are you there did
you sleep over are you i was in this
house i heard this story on the drive-in
dan it's um i don't know what it means i
don't know at all what it means um
except that you've got brady on the
brain
and maybe
you want to
just hang out with them or something i
don't know i i have no idea and you were
with somebody other than your wife yes
okay but i don't even know
like why she was there in the first
place okay because i haven't seen her
since college why were you there in the
first place i don't know i don't know
any of this i love this i just had a
sleepover at tom brady's house we need
more la super bowls is what this means
because it means waking up
really in a god forsaken hour yeah with
someone other than your own wife i mean
this is a total los angeles well no not
in los angeles this was in the dream
he could have been in his brentwood
mance you never know dan maybe i should
uh get out of this right now okay sorry
he's uh rich eisen our good buddy oh
thank you is that a walk-off sucker walk
back row
back row richard thank you uh nfl
network and uh it starts at nine eastern
on super bowl sunday
i love emphasizing you know when when
somebody goes
billions in tv when you say eight and a
half hours
because that's forever it takes forever
it actually started five minutes ago
ever
thought that's where he was going
actually
the playmaker michael irvin in the on
deck circle oh you've got to ask him
about brady his take on brady coming out
of retirement you will enjoy his answer
okay that's a tease there you go we're
back after this in the dan patrick show